dans la catégorie du chien tellement
humain qui nous manque que la parole une
ford fiesta les nommés sont billy le
chien tranquillou bilou devant la
téloche bref ma gueule c'est lors de la
virée de la clape plus quoi il il n'est
même pas 18 heures je commence
maintenant tyson qui a plus de points
que toi sur son permis de conduire
ces trois d'écolo à détourner tout gagné
[Musique]
et regardez comme fresnes et tyson
gay soit ils en arrivaient ya des
voitures et mon fils comment tu vas
faire prennent freine
friendster piles du pont pour tyson
merci spike le chien précède acheter des
croquettes
il m'a foncé
[Rires]
dessus avec le mettre dehors du chien
qui a une particularité plus
impressionnante que le nez de gilles
verdez regarde
dans la catégorie du chien qui a une
particularité plus impressionnante que
non et de gilles verdez les nommés sont
tus le chien qui tu dois obéir ce dogues
allemands n'est pas un chien comme les
autres il détient le record du plus
grand chien ou monde ce chien mesure 112
cm au garrot et une fois debout sur ses
pattes arrière il dépasse les 2 m il
fait la taille d'un basketteur ça c'est
ce que zeus mangent chaque jour
moujik qui n'a pas sa langue dans sa
poche on a voulu vous présenter mme
ochir regarder un sympathique
saint-bertin à québec c'est peut-être
est-ce regarder sa langue elle était
immense sa langue elle fait parler d'eux
et ils se sentent m bush y est entrée
dans le guide des records et oui le
rugby le shôjo qui tient très chaud
[Musique]
le dernier on aurait dit un lion un
sublime après ce vote pour lui aussi on
vous a pas demandé mais votez pour lui
si vous le savez luis vous avez une
particularité vous comme le chien qu'une
grosse langue non elle a
déjà joué ces sites où les bernois
avaient la même particularité
[Musique]
daniel vous l'essayez nord c'est qu'on
ne s'est pas laissé
déconcentrer ami depuis trente ans c'est
pas vrai c'est pas m'écouter alors alors
toi ça fait venir à commencer une petite
séquence amour parce que vous savez
c'est important pour les animaux pas
fier pour le pour le pour vous en faites
surtout
embrassez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
vous voulez
pas vous gêner
[Applaudissements]
l'intérêt des séquences je ne vous le
demande pas et ne posez pas la question
en panthère ou par exemple quel intérêt
égal merci cents us alors qu'un adn mais
si vous savez pas ce que c'est de quoi
régaler du bagad j'en ai une chez du
magal est la maison coloniale allez on
s'en fout on passe maintenant à les
mettre dehors du chèque qui
contrairement aux chroniqueurs de tpm p
un talent c'est sympa ça
dans la catégorie du lieu qui
contrairement chroniqueur de tb à un
talon et nous met son mari la chaîne qui
ne s'éteindra que des fleurs
[Musique]
à nérac est dense mais sans les stars
du tout bleu toutou qui chante aussi
fort que kaboul
[Musique]
les chiens qui danse comme ça là je vous
jure on aurait dit vous
n'avez pas compris et surtout les
oreilles
bien merci et alors on va poursuivre
avec notre séquence et c'est là c'est ma
préférée c'est le mettre dehors du chien
qui a le qi une poule à ses assassins
vos concerts vous savez quoi vous parlez
[Rires]
dans la catégorie des chiens qui a le qi
d'une poule est nommé sont elles ces
problèmes de vue
qu'il dit
du tout et son gros bâton
[Musique]
ok
lui qui découvre la pluie
[Musique]
alors vous avez tous des chiens ici à
table les chamois ses wagons est déjà
debout c'est vrai que vous avez un chien
bo oui highco un golden retriever de 9
ans de nouveau très bien il va bien il
va très bien et poli et bien élevé j'ai
dit aux gars ensemble c'est du goire
gars avec un chien avait dégagé la
mission instagram
il ya des gens il ya des gens qui payent
des séquences de doga
kelly principe ça permet de faire un
sport en communication avec son chien
c'est très marrant donc il vous rend pas
forcément ce qu'on lui demande
exactement mais quand même on doit dans
la communication et devient % lui aussi
fait des étirements et tout c'est très
sympa donc ça change du footing parfois
on va courir ensemble et parfois on fait
du dogue a way de l'essence vous faites
de la pédicure big ben également non
alors je lui détartre les dents je lui
brosse les dents aussi bien sûr
championnat tout ce qui va avec bien
bien sûr il avoue vous avez donc des
chats béchir de se brosser les dents ah
bon sacha qui devint maire de brosses à
dents je m'en suis rendu compte et qui
sait là-bas mardi jusqu'à ce que je
comprends vos poèmes digérer parce que
si vous devez
donc vous n'avez vous jamais eu d'aidés
cher de votre vie on ma fille là un
chien caramel qui aboie mais qui hurlent
dès qu'il me voit
c'est normal
regardez ma gentille et
bien allez voir c'est comment tu as
entendu vous vous en foutez oui
j'aime voir photo d'allemands ont marché
avec le démettre d'or le maître du chien
qui a le plus de chance de remporter à
thé sportif qu'un tennisman français
c'est pas gentil monsieur des bonds 2020
de france est regardée
dans la catégorie du chien qui a plus de
chance de remporter un titre sportif
qu'un tennisman français les nommer son
oscar le chien pour qui tout va comme
sur des roulettes
6 2
[Musique]
au sam
chi chi le caniche qui déteste prendre
l'assaut seul
cachet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'umih le tout aux qui la met au jour au
fond
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]